let's play a game imagine if democrats
got elected to office and then
immediately froze the bank account and
took away the homes of everyone in
america that donated to the republican
party you don't get due process you
don't get a lawyer nope the government
just shows up to your door and takes
your home away from you the second that
happens there is no more trust in the
financial system the economy stops it's
game over
the world's financial system relies on
trust trust that the money you earn is
yours that it can't be taken away from
you at random if that trust is broken
the financial system is destroyed
the last time this happened the last
time people lost trust in the banking
system we entered into the great
depression well this is exactly what the
west is doing right now to russia and
russian people that aren't even
connected to the russian governments and
while the world is cheering on this
theft i'm here to warn you that we are
on a very slippery slope
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets we're
coming for you ill-begotten gains
[Music]
over in hamburg germany lays a super
yacht but not just any super yachts a
500 foot super yacht called the dill bar
outfitted with two helipads and an 80
foot indoor swimming pool it is the
biggest super yacht in the world in
terms of interior volume it can carry up
to 36 guests and is estimated to be
worth around 600 to 750 million dollars
according to the us treasury almost a
billion dollars for a yacht the owner
russian billionaire business magnate
al-ashir uzmanov who has an estimated
net worth of 20 billion dollars he made
his money in metal and mining
unfortunately for uzmanov the us
treasury designated his yacht and his
private jets as blocked property and
since its blocked property usmanov can't
pay his crew or his docking fees in us
dollars the eu also sanctioned uzmanov
all this meant that it made it
impossible for usmanoff to pay his 80
crew members their wages so the crew was
fired and the yacht remains in the dock
to rot uzmanov called these sanctions
unfair and defamatory customs officers
made their way down to south france's
beautiful coast to a port called la
souta south france is a popular
playground for the wealthy and powerful
from all over including russia and at
this port lied the majestic 280 foot
super yachts called the amury vero or
true love in italian it's built by a
company called oceanco in the
netherlands it carries up the 14 guests
has a master cabin two vip cabins three
double cabins and a twin cabin it ranks
131st in the largest super yachts in the
world and it likely belongs to a man
named igor sicheng the ceo of a russian
oil giant called rosneft whose stock is
down almost 50 percent since the start
of the invasion of ukraine the customs
officers found out that the yacht's
captain was ordered to set sail to
turkey as soon as possible without
completing repairs it had scheduled for
april so they prevented it from setting
sail and they seized it forcing the
captain and the crew to remain on board
no crime was committed no warrants the
only justification was that igor c chain
was the subject of eu sanctions
after the seizure the french politician
in charge of the ministry of public
action and accounts proceeded to brag
about the operation on twitter
over in italy italian officials were on
their own shopping spree this is lady m
with around 65 million euros and
apparently belongs to alexis mordechov
who's behind the russian steel
conglomerate si verstall it was seized
in the port of imperia in northwestern
italy
in another nearby port another yacht
named lina was seized owned by the
russian billionaire gennady temchinka
who's behind the investment firm volga
group
vladimir solaf also met the same fates
except it was his italian villas on lake
combo worth around 8 million euros and
near george clooney's properties there
in response to his villas getting seized
he said quote i bought it pay crazy
amounts of taxes and suddenly someone
makes a decision that this journalist is
now on the list of sanctions
solaf is a talking head on russian state
tv far from the most unbiased news
source out there but i doubt he has any
control over what putin does
in total italy impounded assets totaling
around 150 million dollars over nights
even americans are getting greedy the
manhattan borough president wants to
seize the apartments of russian
billionaires in manhattan without any
due process whatsoever quote time for
these properties to be seized end quotes
a texas congressman wants to seize their
yachts and the department of justice
announced a new task force called klepto
capture to take their money all of this
is being done in the name of putting
pressure on russian oligarchs that
apparently sway putin but according to
some of my trusted russian sources that
are actually connected to these
oligarchs oligarchs don't hold that sort
of power over pune anymore because
there's no extra room at the top for
poon the unspoken relationship between
poon and the oligarchs is more of a you
stay out of my politics and i won't
imprison you and shut down your business
the oligarchs were apparently as
surprised by the invasion of ukraine as
you and i were
switzerland has always been neutral in
every single circumstance which has led
to a very diverse range of clientele
they banged for the nazis in world war
ii hiding the gold they stole from the
jews hitler had a personal bank account
there to receive royalties for his book
meinkopf egyptian spies involved with
torturing people on the behalf of the
cia also banked with the swiss
bureaucrats accused of looting
venezuela's oil wealth arms dealers
corrupt political families drug cartels
mobsters and dictators from the world
over all bank with the swiss if you have
a lot of dirty money swiss banks will
gladly take it it's one of the safest
places to store your money where no one
would investigate fine or freeze
anything it was their trademark for the
last 500 years
that is until russia invaded ukraine
apparently concentration camps are okay
but russia invading ukraine was the last
straw enough for switzerland to break
their 500-year track record to freeze
not just the assets of the russian
government but to freeze the bank
account and property of russian
billionaires even after many of those
billionaires spoke out against russia's
invasion risking their business their
families and their own lives
switzerland also sanctioned over 360
russian politicians businessmen and
public figures
switzerland the country that wouldn't
lift a finger against some of the worst
crimes the world has ever seen suddenly
goes all out against russia launching
the most sanctions against russia
compared to any other country
something big is happening here and it's
not being covered this is how far gone
the global financial system is now and
it's just getting worse
we're choking russia's access
[Applause]
we're choking russia's access to
technology that will sap its economic
strength and weaken its military for
years to come
the message behind the sanctions is
clear if you support the wrong political
group if you're merely associated with
the wrong political group the government
of the world can freeze your bank
account take your house your car your
yacht if you have one everything you
worked for they can take it 100 legally
just because you're associated with the
wrong person first they'll say oh but
this is just for the russians it's just
for the bad guys but the problem with
that is that over time that definition
of the bad guy just keeps growing
just this month the canadian government
froze the bank accounts of the people
involved or that donated to the freedom
protests
the only difference between the canadian
sanctions and the russian sanctions is
that in canada it was obvious that these
sanctions were against an innocent group
of people so there was some backlash the
worst part is that it worked the protest
ended soon after but for the russians
it's one of those rare moments in
history where everyone from all sides of
the aisle all sides of the political
spectrum is buying into the same
narrative that everything russian is bad
we will limit russia's ability to do
business in dollars euros pounds and yen
to summarize this is what the sanctions
on russia really means the money in your
bank account is meaningless the deed to
your house the title to your car all
meaningless because the second you get
painted the enemy the world's
governments are gonna take you for all
you've got
[Music]
so i just wanted to take a second to
reiterate that the war in ukraine is
very very bad and that we should
sanction russia that freezing their
government's assets is probably a good
call but freezing random billionaires
jots and houses and villas and bank
accounts what does that do that's just
my opinion is that's a really bad
precedent and it's definitely opening
the pandora's box for worse things to
come but let me know what you guys think
in the comments below subscribe for more
russian videos coming out that they're
not talking about anywhere else stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you